so the community of tulsa is a million
people um and i'd say you know four
years ago or three and a half years ago
when i arrived um almost four years ago
now um there was maybe i
there's less than ten venture back
startups in the city of tulsa if you
could imagine and um
and you know
we have eight companies in our local
portfolio today we've helped another
30 or 40 companies expand in tulsa um
but the community itself you know a lot
of the young smart people who went off
to university previously you know never
came home because there was nowhere
interesting to work
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright xl
welcome to 20 minute leaders and today
we're in tulsa oklahoma meet michael
bash managing partner of attento capital
the venture arm of the george kaiser
family foundation based in tulsa
oklahoma
born in california and living in new
york city london and tel aviv prior to
moving to tulsa michael has spent most
of his life on the operating side of
startups four years ago he moved to
tulsa to work with gkff to look at ways
of deploying capital that not only
drives returns but also creates jobs and
upward mobility in tulsa
outside of work michael is married with
a beautiful eight-month-old baby his
first named leo michael bash welcome to
20 minute leaders all the way from doing
a b dude quarantine in in tel aviv your
most of the time in tulsa oklahoma but
right now we're we're pretty close to
each other how are you
doing i'm doing well i uh it was quite
quite a uh
complicated process getting into this
country at the moment uh
my wife has a passport but i do not and
i had to get a letter from like
basically the foreign ministry uh to
to get in here and so i'm happy i was
able to do so but it was not simple
well you've done something that many of
my family members are still unable to do
so afterwards we'll talk about a few
tricks of how that's done but right now
michael i want to be focusing on your
work with authentic capital as a
managing director and specifically you
know around tulsa oklahoma and how
you're leveraging the deployment of
capital to empower community you're not
from tulsa oklahoma originally if i
believe
you you know in new york california you
ran for mayor in new york
and so i there's a lot of stories to be
told here uh how do you end up in tulsa
oklahoma
yeah um
so the kind of quick background as i was
born in san francisco and raised in los
angeles i went to university and
graduate school in la and then to new
york london tel aviv new york tulsa um
my background is in startups and if you
would have told me four years ago you
know name 500 cities on earth you might
be living in i wouldn't have thought of
tulsa oklahoma in there and and it was
kind of the last place i expected to be
but uh i built a few different
businesses from coffee shops to a
product manufacturing business to a
mobile user acquisition business
actually at israel and um
and then left briefly to work on in
politics on hillary clinton's campaign
in 2016 uh we lost and then i ran for
mayor of new york as one does which is
the long story for a summer day and then
um and then and then after that i
visited tulsa uh actually a couple i'd
introduced i ended up getting married um
and i met a guy by the name of george
kaiser um who has a family foundation um
whose main mission is to address
intergenerational poverty and actually
fun fact his son was in the idf he was a
paratrooper and met his wife in israel
now wow
and they have an israeli restaurant but
uh but an israeli restaurant in tulsa
oklahoma
yeah yeah right a block from my office
is very dangerous but um
but uh
yeah look i think um
you know the foundation is a four
billion dollar foundation um previously
you know they spend 99 of their
philanthropy in tulsa but they spend 99
of their investment outside of tulsa and
they don't really do anything early
stage because such a big you know
they're writing massive checks and so
you know the thesis is can we can we
invest earlier stage in ways with
intentionality beyond just returns which
were you know dead focused on but also
in a way that can create jobs in tulsa
and so um
you know we've deployed about 40 million
dollars in that strategy over the last
two years
incredible and you know with coming into
this new location you know how do you
find yourself interact with this mission
you know of of the playing capital to
empower the community what do you have
to do in order to get acquainted with
the community on a personal level to
understand both financially but but also
you know just say you know in the day to
day about what it takes
so the community of tulsa is a million
people um and i'd say you know four
years ago three and a half years ago
when i arrived um almost four years ago
now um there was maybe i
there's less than 10 venture back
startups in the city of tulsa if you
could imagine and um
and you know we
have eight companies in our local
portfolio today we've helped another
30 or 40 companies expand expanded tulsa
um
but the community itself you know a lot
of the young smart people who went off
to university previously you know never
came home because there was nowhere
interesting to work and so it's been
about kind of creating opportunity it's
kind of been personal seeing who's here
what the potential is of the group of
people that are here you know creating
opportunity for the people who were from
there that have left to entice them to
come back and then trying to bring in
you know talented people that build big
companies that that can create upward
mobility for the people that are there
and so
um it's been
you know the community the most
interesting thing about the community is
they're very
they're they welcome
you know they're very welcoming and some
you'd think they could be threatened by
this and they're not they're they're
seeing it as a great opportunity they
they're kind of excited that people are
trying to kind of grow the tech
ecosystem and diversify the economy the
the legacy industries you know
fossil fuels largely it's like oil and
gas and so you know they know that you
know they have to figure out what the
future is um otherwise they'll be
detroit 2009 and so so it's been a you
know really interesting process i'd say
the biggest challenge of the community
for me when i arrived coming from new
york is that you know
as i talk fast and walk fast and move
fast and it's definitely there's a thing
called tulsa time um which is which is
like you know there's no hurry and so
you know living on tulsa time is a big
thing and so that was probably the
biggest adjustment
right and and how does that impact then
you know the the mission of of attention
capital to
you know what a traditional venture
capitalist might might be expecting of
themselves or their lp's would be
expecting them i believe that you know
there's a different structure not
necessarily a multiple lp traditional
structure but how does that impact you
know your investment thesis your
rationale as you're approaching these
different opportunities and that that
you know you know you're already doing
yeah so so a typical vc
um so we so a little bit about attention
we have kind of
two strategies one is we invest locally
and precede season a we lead um and we
is and
tulsa but two-thirds of our local deals
we actually found a company and
relocated the founders and so the
founder could be in boston or
johannesburg or st louis or or
san antonio and we'd relocate them to
tulsa and we could sit at a local
company because they're basically
interesting
and
what was their response so they have you
have this you know tulsa-based vc fund
coming in leading the round and then
asking them or encouraging them to
relocate to tulsa oklahoma to develop
their strategy and their company
what's the feedback that you're getting
on this
so i mean look it's definitely not for
everyone and i wouldn't i wouldn't i
wouldn't approach you know someone in
san francisco or new york and say hey
move to tulsa because in san francisco
new york you have a ton of vcs a ton of
talent it's all there but if you're in
st louis if you're in if you're in
oklahoma city if you're in kansas city
if you're in
johannesburg or san antonio and these
places that aren't that developed you
know the interesting thing about our
structure versus a typical vc is a
typical vc is limited by its fees
meaning um they have a two and a half
percent of their invested capital to run
the vc or two percent maybe and then
they get a percentage of carry for us
you know we're investing in partnership
with the george kaiser family foundation
off the balance sheet and we're not
limited by the typical fee structure and
so
we have much you know quite a bit more
resources to give our founders so we can
give them free office space free
recruiting services you know we've at
times put people full-time in their
portfolio companies in the portfolio to
to do sales if they've had a big
opportunity to like grab but do a land
grab you know given a regulatory change
um and so we you know we can dig in
much deeper post investment with our
portfolio companies to help to help you
know
give them an unfair advantage to be
successful and so if i'm a super early
stage founder and i've got one vcu
here's half a million dollars um you
know and they're just gonna invest in
another vc or half a million dollars
they give me free office space they're
gonna set me up with advisors they're
gonna you know you know give me you know
free housing for six months free
recruiting services you know real you
know
strategy consulting from xbcg
consultants that we have working with us
um you know it's you know we really try
to wrap around and give them an unfair
advantage of being successful because if
you're going towards oklahoma and not in
san francisco new york you need the help
it means harder and you're competing
with the san francisco new york company
and so
so we have to be the difference i mean
it's very binary right we're investing
with the first generally the first check
in the company and so we have to help be
the difference from zero to one um to
get them over that hurdle and then we
have a non-local strategy which is
investing in funds and then you know
there's two parts funds and direct spun
the funds we we invest typically at the
precede and then we invest in seed stage
funds and then we
that are generally specialist funds
non-locally and those funds that look at
our pre-seed companies and hopefully
lead the seed round so we invested in a
company last year called respondflow
through the pre-seed investment um you
know you know you know three three point
three three million dollar cap i think
on the pre-seed in in tulsa still exists
um
i haven't seen that in about uh in about
two years i haven't seen anything below
a 5 million cap
yeah so so and then and then uh and then
our seed fund is in our portfolio
mercury
led the seed round um their seed nathan
they led the seed round in july and it
was a two and a half x markup for us and
so that's exactly kind of what we're
trying to do we recruited the company
from oklahoma city moved them to tulsa
they were doing 50k in revenue when we
invested in the last may they're doing
ander kane revenue in july wow
you know a year and a couple months
later our c fund comes in invest leads
to 3 million 2.5 million dollar round
you know two and a half x markup and
that's kind of what we're trying to
duplicate now they have 25 employees in
tulsa and so that's that's like the
exact like profile of an outcome that
we're looking for
okay and i guess that then a part of the
part of sort of the kpis or the goals
here is that the companies don't just
start in tulsa but as they grow they
they also choose to to keep to keep a
strong presence either the their
headquarters or or just a strong
presence and tulsa and thereby you know
promoting and encouraging the the tech
the tech scene over there right
yeah so i mean i think um
you know we want we want the founders
there specifically because of the
founders to have attachments to the
place and we want to connect our
advisors and employees et cetera to
build a team there you know in a perfect
world we want to find them i've
introduced 12 married couples and and i
want to find them a significant other
that'll really keep them um but but uh
but we're really trying to
you know
help create you know have big companies
that are built here and
and i think that you know we also i
didn't mention this earlier but we also
are if you look at our portfolio we have
a strong eye for the diversity of the
people we invest in you know over half
our founders are immigrants um a lot of
our founders are minorities um we were
the first people ever in the history of
oklahoma that we know of they ever
invest in a black founder we've invested
in three uh three different countries
that are co-founded by black and so so
we really you know we're trying to
create kind of opportunity for people
who are typically under invested we
think there's alpha in that and so um
and so
so yeah so i think
you know
for our local strategy the fed we want
the founders there staying there for our
non-local strategy you know series a
series b series c we're not leading
we'll take a secondary office so you
know i'm in israel there's two companies
in our portfolio from israel percepto
and c3 um there are co-investments one
of our funds called hanako and both the
both of them have
hired people in tulsa and so we invest
for returns
unilaterally but in addition if we can
capture some jobs great
i love it now i'm reading off of the
website directly in your philosophy but
the name attento comes from the spanish
word meaning helpful attentive
thoughtful courteous and polite these
are the adjectives we aspire to be in
the foundation of how we do business
tell me a little bit about the doing
business part once you've you know found
the right team the right part of the
right market what does this mean to be a
tento while you were while you're doing
business with your founders and their
employees
yeah so attentive so my wife's from
argentina and she made aliyah to israel
and so uh and so attentive spanish and
it's kind of a shout out to her heritage
um
but uh
but look i mean i think you know a lot
of
you know at the core you know i see
venture capital especially the earliest
of stages is how do we help these
founders
how do you unlock and the potential of
these founders and help them achieve
their maximum potential right and like
you know in part of our culture like we
believe in giving without the hope of
receiving and like trying to make the
world a better place a lot of ways
and
and even if it's a company we're not
investing with if we can help them we
can still get a customer or an uh
an advisor or a potential investor or
every meeting we have we want to try and
have the people we need would be better
for it even if they have nothing to gain
from the personality just culturally how
we want to be and so um
you know with our founders
if nothing else like even if we don't
agree with all the decisions they make
we want to be helpful to them um to do
everything we can to see them achieve
um and so that really is like at the
core and also internally to our team
members like our our managers which we
call 10 managers um
um you know even internally you know
every meeting you want to see like how
can i be helpful like how can we what is
it you're looking for
you need how can we help facilitate it
and that really is like culturally
deeply embedded in who we are
right and so if you're looking down the
line and looking at what you've learned
about making a positive impact on the
community and the founders that you're
working with what are some bigger ideas
that you're distilling from your
experience
that you know somebody who hasn't gone
through your experience of being both
deeply embedded within the community
whether it's working on the hillary
campaign running for mayor in the in new
york city and now working with the
central capital but at the same time
being very very much you know tech
and and capital focused because that
that's a part of what the work requires
what did you learn about the
intersection of the two
yeah so i mean uh you know kind of the
big learning for me you know especially
said look at all these like big
metropolises before tulsa is there's no
silver bullet when i got when i arrived
in tulsa
um
the first people wanted to recruit tech
companies i was talking to friends of
mine at casper uber or wherever and they
said find me talent um and the talent
base wasn't there you know it's not like
you know in that because we didn't have
a ton of tech companies to recruit from
so we were going to find talent um the
talent needed jobs and it was very
complicated and so they should develop a
program called tulsa remote that pays
remote workers ten thousand dollars to
work remotely in tulsa and like sixty
thousand people applied and a thousand
people have moved
up on the talent side but then we also
wanted to create upward mobility and so
you know if i'm a person who grew up on
the wrong side of poverty you know how
do you make this how do you get this
person to be a tech entrepreneur well
they can't just start a company they
know nothing about tech so you have to
create programs and you have a program
called satellite which is a sales force
development program or or holberton was
a software development program or um
foundry college was a project management
program and all of which gkff actually
covers the cost of for the students to
go through the programs and hopefully
that will get a random human into a tech
company and they can work at a tech
company for a few years and hopefully a
few years then they can start a tech
company and we can invest and so we're
trying to kind of create these pipelines
you know for people that are from here
but the biggest thing i think the
biggest learning is it's going to take
like five years at least to even see
signs of
of this is working in ten years to even
know is it's not it's a level of
patience i've never really had um
previously and so
so we will see
i love it and so
now that you're looking a little bit
more broadly about you know the tallest
scene today versus before and and where
it's headed and you know we're looking
at obviously different communities
around the world and specifically tulsa
has the gift of having you there to now
continue the tech scene and to invest
locally but i'm thinking you know about
the different you know the dozens of
other cities in the world or the
hundreds of other cities in the world
that would love to have a presence of a
cap of a of a vc fund that is so active
in their area is this a model that if
replicated could succeed around the
world is this a model that should be
replicated in order to empower cities to
grow into more tech hubs
so i really think i mean you think about
temasik in singapore and you think about
the waltons northwest arkansas the
walmart family i think you have these
like huge multi-billion dollar
organizations with the sovereign funds
of uae or saudi
you know i think is you have these
multi-billion dollar balance sheets
in the saudis by the way they pay like
english teachers 100 000 i mean they're
doing a lot of things in different ways
of like kind of developing i think
the these billion dollar organizations
that are place based must do something
to develop their community into tomorrow
and so that's that that's from an
individual perspective as well as a kind
of a a jobs perspective so you need
individuals that can participate in the
economy tomorrow any jobs you need jobs
that that they can go into which is kind
of the venture capital side of it and so
i think um
i think there will become a time where
you know they have so many multi-billion
dollar vcs that they'll just say instead
of being lps and vcs they're going to do
themselves off their own balance sheet
and they're going to realize that
they're going to want to do it in a
place-based way and they'll start adding
these other things with the pipelines
and so i think i think you're already
starting to see a lot of these
family offices and family foundations
have their own venture arm and and
then the waltons are probably doing the
most similar version and they're only a
couple hours away and close partners and
so and so um i think this will happen
more and more
michael take me back a little bit to
your childhood what really fascinates
you as a kid
um
i feel like my childhood was like split
between
selling lemonade which was very
lucrative in los angeles um and playing
magic cards
i love it and what inspires you today in
your day today out of everything that
you're doing whether professional
professionally or or private or
professionally or personally
god inspires is a tricky word um
so emote i say what motivates me i mean
i feel like
motivates me is i
there's i i feel a heavy burden in terms
of like where a lot of ways by the
direction of the world be it
climate or wealth gap or education some
of the big problems of the world and i
feel like it's a race against time in
terms of how much i can do to try and
contribute my part to helping to repay
to prepare the world while i'm still
alive
and and and uh it kind of makes me
obsessed with work unfortunately it's an
unhealthy amount but i i think i think
it's just a race against time against
your mind on how much the maximum impact
you can have on earth and that's that's
that's mine would have made motivation
which i don't know if it's good or bad
and what are three words that you would
use to describe yourself
um i hope helpful um
i'm not i might i'd say helpful i hope
helpful i'm a connector i'm someone that
loves introducing people bringing people
together um that's like my life's my
biggest passion
and um
and hopefully a good husband and father
i have an old baby and
and he's crying behind me a little bit
right now and an amazing wife and so it
would be the three ways
i love it well michael i'll let you get
back to your family and thank you very
much for taking the time and for the
energy for doing this i really
appreciate it and stay safe and stay
healthy and thank you for the great work
that you're doing
thank you for having me
take care bye